[Music]  thank you for joining us i'm john  langler we do start with that breaking  news near chicago this is a live look at  the scene near a fourth of july parade  there's been a mass shooting again this  is sort of in the highland park area  near chicago police say this happened  about 10 o'clock this morning police  also say six people were killed at least  two dozen others are in the hospital  officers believe they are still they  tell us they are still looking for the  suspect right now and police believe  that person opened fire from a rooftop  they have recovered the gun this is a  developing story we'll have more all  throughout the day